lydia travaille comme secrétaire de
direction dans une société de
restauration façade depuis maintenant
deux ans dans quelques années elle
prendra sa retraite et la relève est
déjà tout trouvé avec marie embauché le
mois dernier ensemble elles forment un
duo la junior épaulé par la senior un
exemple concret du contrat de génération
mis en place au début de l'année à 21
ans et sans diplôme marine a donc signé
son premier cdi et c'est pour elle un
grand soulagement c'est la stabilité du
poste fils tu que je vois ça j'ai
franchement
galéré en restauration
dans le sein d'an dans le domaine
de la vente je suis beaucoup de choses
de son côté lydia reste en poste et
transmet son savoir faire et son
expérience à la nouvelle recrue ce n'est
que spécifiquement un rôle de
transmission c'est comment dire le
plaisir d'apporter à une junior
méconnaissance mon expérience et puis
principalement l'amour du travail dans
la globalité qui on a tout repris enfin
n'ont pas repris les prix à la base tout
le travail
concernant les facturations on est de
vie enfin la formulation des courriers
pour inciter ce type de collaboration
intergénérationnelle
l'état verse pendant trois ans 4000
euros par duo à toute entreprise de
moins de 300 salariés mais lydia est
persuadé que sa petite entreprise
familiale aurait eu la même démarche
sensée z c'est selon elle une question
d'évolution des liens entre générations
il ya une plus grande compréhension
disons des seniors vis-à-vis des juniors
le système n'est plus le même c'est à
dire que le seigneur ne considère pas
que l'un juniors où le junior va prendre
sa place
tel que ça pouvait se passer à mon
époque et c'est plus une transmission
c'est plus l'aide au développement de la
société après soit un bel état d'esprit
qui omet cependant la hausse du chômage
des seniors selon la direccte 15 autres
entreprises yvelinoise ont mis en place
un contrat de génération